ok let's go to something a little
lighter today instead of voicemails I
have a beautiful email for you today
I got a an email from someone who says
that my pronunciation has cured their
depression Chris wrote to me and said
hey David
your pronunciation of Pete Buddha jej
and Tulsi Gabbard cured my depression
thank you you know the funny thing about
Buddha jej is when Pete Buddha judge at
the beginning was not well known a lot
of people didn't know how to pronounce
his last name and he came out and said
it's very easy it's three words boots
edge edge and so I've just been
pronouncing it that way Pete Buddha edge
even though I'm not running it together
the way normal person might do I'm glad
that you like it I'm glad that you liked
me referring to the candidate as Tulsi
and hope I don't know how serious this
is but to any extent that I can help
someone if they are in a tough spot or
or feeling depressed I am glad to be
able to be a part of that thanks Chris
appreciate it we've got a great bonus
show for you today Elizabeth Warren is
proposing criminal penalties for
spreading voting disinformation online
we will also have two border related
stories one serious the longest ever
border smuggling tunnel has been found
stretching between Tijuana and San Diego
and a piece of the US border wall just
fell over it was windy so the border
wall fell over onto the Mexican side
yeah we'll talk about all of those
stories and more on the bonus show two
ways to get instant access to the bonus
show number one become a member at join
pakman.com please sign up folks please
sign up that's my Jeb Bush please clap
quote and you can become a patron at the
$5 or greater level to also get instant
access to the bonus show
that's patreon.com slash david pakman
show I'll speak to you then or otherwise
tomorrow